it is time to turn that great idea that
you have into a reality
and squarespace is going to help you do
it they make it easier than ever to
launch your passion project
whether you're showcasing your work or
selling products of any kind they have
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything
so you can easily make a beautiful
website all by yourself
but if you do get stuck which happens
squarespace's 24 7 award-winning
customer support
is there to help you out so head to
squarespace.com grace
for a free trial and when you are ready
to launch use the offer code grace to
save 10
of your first purchase of a website or
domain
hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep
i am your host grace helbig a very
exciting
episode awaits you we have none other
than bob
the drag queen with us oh i'm so excited
for this
we talked about uh the four different
times that he auditioned for drag race
fourth time's a charm we talk about the
experience
of creating the beautiful and wonderful
hbo show we're here
we also talk about his new idea that i
think should get made any producers
anyone
out there that's willing to make this
show please flip the cairns
you know we're talking about flipping
the senate and bob has a mission to flip
the cairns and it's
oh so perfect we actually uh we actually
we actually
talk a lot about the lottery and how
that can help benefit
the youth in our country uh we i mean we
talk about everything so please
enjoy this episode of not too deep with
the so hilarious so sweet
bob the drag queen
oh bob thank you for being here of
course my budger
uh you've put yourself together in all
of 30 seconds and i am so impressed i
put myself together in like an hour and
this is what i've come up with so
kudos to you no you look great we're all
looking great here
we're all doing the best we can um i
have to say
i am so impressed one um with your
social media influence you've gotten to
work with brands like coach
and party city all within months of each
other
and that's quite the spectrum yeah that
is such a feat
uh i have to ask how is you've dedicated
uh
yourself to youtube more in this like
pandemic quarantine how is that going
for you
yeah it's going pretty well i mean i'm
not like one of the million subscriber
youtubers or anything well you've also
just like started it feels like
yeah i just really got into the
youtubing so i mean i
i can't tell if what i'm doing is on
track or
what but it feels good to be creating
content you know
yeah what was the um catalyst or
inspiration to actually start uh
planning out more youtube stuff
well it's not like i can get out in the
world and do stuff so
now i'm just you know
working with me yeah we're gonna go yeah
i'm i'm adjusting to 20
20. yeah i mean by the way bear is
barely 20. it's almost 21 at this point
i know uh time is a very strange
system this year i feel like so what
er what's been the best part about being
able to
do youtube content now i mean it feels
like you have obviously creative control
you can do whatever the [ __ ] you want
there
like do you feel like it uh has been
like a creative outlet like something
that's been helpful
yeah i mean it keeps me the one of the
best parts that just keeps me busy
from you know instead of sitting in my
home wishing i could reach
out to people who appreciate my work i
actually can and i can also reach people
also through like the live shows and
stuff i'm able to reach people who
i could basically not reach before yeah
that must be
a very cool thing i mean that's we've
been um having a lot of different
creatives on the show lately and it's
really inspiring to see how resourceful
everyone has been
over the last few months uh which is
very very cool
now i have you learned anything about
yourself
over the last couple months in having to
kind of pivot and navigate the world
i mean i'm sure but i think i learned
something about myself every couple of
months
yeah i i hope i i would like to be
self-aware enough to
to to discover myself as time goes on
and i'd be like i've got it all figured
out
kid you know what i mean yeah no one
likes that no one likes that person
or wants to be that person i don't want
to be that person i can't speak
government i don't want to be that
person
yeah um but i i feel like
yeah maybe i've learned like a little
bit about myself i don't i don't i don't
know that i can articulate
what i've learned so i mean i don't know
that the movie's over yet
so that i already have that i've made
that i've and i also don't want people
to feel like they have to like
like anyone listening you don't have to
like
come out of quarantine or out of 2020.
everyone's like well i'm in the house
like i gotta learn five languages
i gotta be able to i gotta be skinnier
than i ever was
i have to know how to macrame uh real
point
um you know i can sew now
no i think that's great um because there
is yeah
that i i've struggled at the beginning
of the pandemic of feeling like
okay i have all this free time i have to
put it to good use but then sometimes
you just don't have the motivation or
inspiration to put it to good use so
it really is on your own timeline and
giving yourself permission
um okay can we go back to the beginning
for people that
might not know who you are or how you
started
uh you were born and raised in georgia
yeah i was running
i was running columbus georgia and i was
raised throughout the south but mostly
georgia
okay and i i your mom owned a bar
that uh drag was performed at yeah it
was called sensations
my mom owned like a gay bar that did
drag shows yeah
sensations in columbus georgia i mean
that's um
a very interesting career for a mom to
have what was it like growing up in that
environment
um well i mean i also want to create
this uh this idea that it was like a
long
lasting establishment for like a pillar
in the community
um you know the the gay cheers it wasn't
bad
um my mom and a bunch of lesbians
started to open a bar and i think the
bar
lasted for like three years maybe okay
wow but i mean still pretty substantial
and what an amazing kind of
um thing to decide that you're gonna
start
especially with kids now how did you
first was that your first like uh
intro into the world of drag or how did
that start
i mean it started with tv and film uh i
think chuang fu was the first time i saw
a drag queen in a film or maybe
her drag mention was actually in the
lion king
a lot of people remember there's a scene
where timon and pumbaa and simba and
rafiki
are all trying to storm pride rock now
that scar is taking over
yeah and then simba goes i need you to
create a distraction
and then to moon says what do you want
to do dress and drag and do the hula
uh yeah and then it cuts to
moon wearing a hula skirt and a coconut
bra and puma's on a plate with an apple
on his mouth
and then uh he then uh he sings a song
making and sing the song wow okay
yeah you've just changed a big
perspective for me
what do you want to do dress the dragon
do the hula yeah i do
wow um now i want to go back and watch
the movie specifically for that scene
right and they did not put it in the
remake they didn't
oh god what a missed opportunity
uh so that's your first uh actual um
encounter with that how do you start
performing how does that i don't know
let me
see okay google when did two wong fu
come out
in the united states yeah so two of you
came out the next year so it was
definitely the lying game
okay wow it might have been like it also
could have been bugs bunny
like dressing up in drag but like
hearing it called
drag yeah the first time was lion king
wow
that's wild how interesting and also
i guess when you look back at a lot of
like um you know childhood entertainment
it's probably infused in a lot of areas
without you even
recognizing necessarily yeah there's
probably some queen on staff writing for
uh
yeah probably so what is your
when was your first show when was your
first attempt at doing drag
my first show was the new york comedy
club about 12 years ago
i went and i did some stand up that was
my first show it was my first time
dressing up in drags
my first time doing it in front of an
audience was at the new york company
club doing
that wow okay so that's a layered
uh situation i'm sure so not only are
you doing stand up but you're doing
stand-up and drag
yeah wow so have you always wanted to do
stand-up was that something that was
just sort of
like you're obviously a funny person and
i'm sure as soon as you're a funny
person people encourage you like
you should make jokes well
i when i was younger i had a lot of
judgment i wanted to be an accountant i
wanted to be a candy maker i wanted to
be
a candidate i remember just wanting to
be martin luther king
um like just wanting to be like whatever
mark kings does
i want to do that i want to be in front
of movement like listen everyone let's
roll up and you know get yeah
um and then somehow it all then i found
acting and then
through that i found out that i was
funny and then i was like maybe i should
stand up and try i didn't
i didn't start like writing or thinking
about standing up i was like 19.
wow which seems early i'm like i'm like
not do i was but i was also
like 19 though yeah i mean i guess that
is young
in stand-up terms and what was it like
getting into stand-up because especially
the new york stand-up scene is
difficult yeah well you know so
um are you standing up i did i've done
improv in new york for years before i
moved out to la it's stand-up scares the
[ __ ] out of me
um i've done like storytelling and that
kind of thing but
i know a lot of stand-ups got it
yeah sorry to hear that yeah i know i
keep trying to cheer them up and they
don't want that
no stand-ups are miserable
yeah the genus species of stand up right
um you don't know like stand up in new
york there's a couple ways you can do it
there's like this is called a bringer
show a bringer show
is where you get you're allowed to do
the show if you could bring a certain
number of people it's usually like three
or five people
you can bring five people to the show
you're allowed to get on stage and tell
your jokes
i started doing bringers bringers people
despise bringers in the stand-up world
yeah because it does not guarantee your
show will be funny and just guarantee
that you will have an audience that is
yeah
guarantees there will be people
breathing in the room with you
exactly and there's also like uh uh
there's like uh
you can get you can earn a seat at a
show
by selling tickets so you can go into
the street
and like try to get tickets to a show
and then if you sell
certain tickets you can actually get to
be in a show that's another one and then
it's also like if you just
keep doing enough open mics eventually
someone will ask you to do your show
yeah i did the bringer version which
people would just i wouldn't recommend
it actually honestly it was great that
was funny
and i had like all my friends from work
laughing i enjoyed it i thought it was
[ __ ] great most music like don't do a
bringer
[ __ ] it turned me out
it is when you put it in those terms i'm
like oh stand up comedy is just a
pyramid scheme
then it's just bring five of your
friends
no uh let's talk about auditioning for a
drag race
uh where does this come into play in
your career
i've had to sit for directors four times
four times
yeah so i mean i i was auditioning for
direct race around season four which was
2012.
dang it was my first no whatever season
4 was
i think it was 2012 uh or 2011 maybe
my first time auditioning and i didn't
get on 2015.
wow so what kept you re-auditioning
i mean it wasn't it was just like a
little chunk of my
like my like it was like a week of work
right but then it's not like i wasn't
still doing drag
i was still doing everything else right
and then i was like oh let me just go
and audition for this thing
maybe i'll get on it maybe not and then
if i didn't get on i would just keep
doing my thing and i was still enjoying
my life as a drag queen as a comedian
and an actor um but i would also just
take time to audition for a revolution
right now i live in l.a now and i
thought you were still in new york i was
like that sounds like new york
it does like la is louder than new york
no one's going to talk about that
no one talks about that la is louder
than new york
yeah how is it like how long have you
been in los angeles now
like a little over a week oh okay so
fresh fresh brand new brand new yeah
how uh what are the major differences
for you or what's the um
the getting used to it part like well i
mean i've been to l.a so and i've spent
a significant amount of time in life so
this isn't culture shock
right now it's just not having my things
i mean i've been renting this room in
l.a
since beginning of the year i was just
been going back and forth but then i
ended up being in new york the whole
time because of pandemic
yeah um but i
just not being with all my stuff is a
little strange to be honest
oh i'm sure yeah especially when all
we've been doing for the last like seven
months is being around all of our stuff
all the time yeah
when i was back in new york city i was
just like you know
yeah you have your system i just
literally it was like literally click
boom
high and then it was like all the lights
falling over
i'm sitting on the floor i have my my
house shoes on my hands
i don't know what's going on but see
this is you're just you
you're still you at the end of the day
this is the real me this is the real me
everyone
so okay fourth time's a charm you get
onto the show
did you do any um prep did you talk to
anyone beforehand did you get any advice
because when you
came onto the show you seemed very
steadfast in who you are
what you have to offer yeah i mean i
didn't have any
friends who were on drag race before me
okay i mean kind of i mean bianca and i
our relationship grew after drag race i
mean her and i did we did a show
together before
so after she filmed drag race and before
her season aired her and i did a show
together
okay so we had that relationship but we
didn't actually become like friends
friends
until after that gig and then i got on
the year after that so she won someone
else won then i got on the show
gotcha okay and then what was your
experience like because i'm fascinated
the part that i wish that they showed
more of that they don't is like what
happens after you rap for the day
and you guys all have to like be
sequestered remotely fascinating
you wouldn't want to watch this at all
it's
it's quarantining before quarantine but
it's quarantined without
any elect without the internet wow
and without a phone so it's literally
just a bunch of drag queens
i mean we would leave the the room and
just like
pass out like we would get back to our
rooms and we
wake up and then we'd be back in the
work room jeez yeah it must have been
like a fever dream
the whole time i mean it was
it was really because it's very
systematic
and it we were on a schedule so it was
like
i was a morning person which i had never
been
so i was like it didn't feel i didn't
feel like a zombie i didn't feel quite
there's a moment where you feel a little
nutty because
you're going against what you typically
do in life
right because like typically you get to
talk to
your loved ones and and you know you
don't eat
a lot or maybe you actually i guess this
eating
is different than whatever eating
schedule was before because you're
eating when they
offer you food basically and you know
i'm drinking like nothing but red bulls
so maybe i was a little bit on edge but
not too far from my life
anyway so then what to you
was the most interesting or surprising
other than winning obviously uh when you
sign that i didn't find winning
surprising well yeah
i bet you did it i wasn't surprised at
all actually
well that's the thing too is that you
had such a uh
i was gonna say quiet confidence maybe
not quiet confidence you had such a
a confidence the whole time that it was
really fun to watch because i guess you
didn't make
an audience nervous like you just felt
like you always had a handle on exactly
what you wanted to do
and even if you didn't you were very
aware and like
in tune with that well i mean i really
wanted to win
and yeah i didn't feel the need to be
shy about it yeah
yeah yeah yeah the so after you win
what's that year like
of being the winner of rupaul's drag
race
i mean it's a combination of like a lot
of responsibility
that you're placing yourself really
because it's not like world of wonder or
rupaul is like you got to do this stuff
right they just give you the money until
you go about your business
and we'll see you in a year when you
give up the crown that there's there's
no duties yeah
you know you just do whatever the hell
you want to do and i remember wanting to
make an
impact and wanting to um
be a i don't know like
i i wanted to get make the most of my
year you know
yeah i mean it seems like you have
because you've gone into a billion other
projects since then
um let's talk about purse first too
because this uh it's fun because you get
to watch it evolve
on the show itself that you didn't come
in with that idea
no i didn't come in being like first
first i'm gonna do a thing it just like
it
or it happened organically it happened
because thorgy yeah was a dear friend of
mine was like
we are like how do we all walk out and i
said i walked out like this like you
know like with my she was like how did
you walk out and say i woke up like this
like
my first verse and then we started kind
of like joking about how it sounded like
a song
and then i made up this little song on
the spot and then
i started carrying the person because i
thought it was funny and then it just
kind of took on its own life and now i'm
like
holding bags for coach
i know now do you think about like what
do i actually need or want in my life
and how do i brand that for myself
can't come to you a million dollars
first and then you know maybe the
lottery will sponsor me or some [ __ ]
all right uh well in terms of your music
think about that i wonder when they like
if people
do a commercial for the lottery yeah how
much are
they getting paid like the people like
yeah because the people because the
lottery they make a lot of money
does i mean yeah have we ever
investigated the whole lottery system
how much money are they actually making
i mean it favors the house i mean
they're if they're able to give away
multiple millions of dollars a year
right mama they're doing well
are you you know in georgia i don't play
the lottery at all
at all i don't think i'm lucky enough to
do that
you're practical yeah but um i do gamble
when i go to casinos i don't play the
lottery
so in georgia they have something called
the hope scholarship
and give you an idea of how well the
lottery's doing
in georgia because of the georgia
lottery every single
student who graduates from high school
with a b average or above
goes to college for free is that for
real
and it's paid for by the georgia lottery
which is one of the things where people
are like
we can't do social life there's no way
that americans can go to college for
freedom like americans are already going
for college for free
the state i'm from people go to college
for free all the time
wow yes so mary we already have
socialism popping off
wow that's really interesting great to
know
um okay we're going to take a quick
break when we get back i have a billion
more questions for you so we'll be right
back we're not too deep
[Music]
it is time for you to turn that dream
into a reality with squarespace
squarespace makes it easier than ever to
launch your passion project which i'm
sure we've all had a few
over the last eight months whether
you're looking to start a new business
showcase your work publish content
sell products or more squarespace is the
tool for you they have beautiful
templates created by world-class
designers and the ability to customize
just about anything with a few clicks
so you can easily make a beautiful
website all by yourself
plus they have a powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and analytics that help
you grow your site in real time
and everything is optimized for mobile
right out of the box there's nothing to
patch or upgrade
ever buying domains is super simple and
you can get the help you need with their
24
7 award-winning customer support
squarespace empowers millions of peoples
from peoples yeah you heard me millions
of peoples
from designers to lawyers artists to
gamers even restaurants and gyms to turn
great ideas
into something real so head to
squarespace.com grace for a free trial
and when you are ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com
grace over code grace
okay so uh let's talk about we're here
how did this idea
come to you were you part of the initial
like uh
inception of this so it's not we're here
is not my idea we're here
uh with the idea of uh johnny ingram and
steve steven warren
um steven is a hollywood lawyer and
johnny ingram is like a photographer and
creative
art director and so i got a cold call
like a hollywood cold call
wow i answer my phone no matter who
calls even if i don't recognize that i'm
right i always i actually think it's
really important to answer your phone
you do not matter every time my phone
rings if i see it i answer
that i feel like you are very you're a
unicorn for that
well it's also because i have no qualms
hanging up on people
like it doesn't bother me being like if
someone's like
hey i'm just wondering if i'll just hang
up like hey don't
don't hang up i'm like bye yeah i guess
i forget that you have control of the
situation when you answer your
phone if it's a telemarketer i'm like i
will never see you
ever and if i do you won't notice me so
like whatever what does it matter
and i'm saving you time because i'm not
gonna buy whatever you're trying to sell
me so just like
i'm say i'm saving you time right you're
giving them notes basically
right um so and even if i'm too busy to
talk
unless i'm like actually filming
something if i'm getting ready i'll
answer and be like
hey i can't talk right now i'll call you
back bye always answer my
okay good for you so you got one of
those phone calls you picked it up yes
and he was like hey i have an idea for
this it was steven warren he was like i
have an idea for the show
but i can't take over the phone it's
super secret we have to meet at a
restaurant in new york city that
sounds like a movie premise like that
sounds
hilarious and dangerous he was like
bring a briefcase with one million
dollars
handcuffed to yourself yeah get rid of
your fingerprints there we go
yeah rub your fingers in lemon juice for
a week
to get rid of your fingerprints um but
yeah and it was
pretty um chill like we he told me the
concept
and i really liked it he really told me
when he typically be telling stories of
marginalized people like
i didn't wanted to be like queers fix
straight people's lives like that would
have driven me crazy and we didn't know
that i'm so glad we did not make that
show
yeah it's i mean the show is beautiful
and very real what was your experience
like
shooting it because i mean you have this
concept in mind and then you really
don't know how it's going to go until
you start meeting these questions
i can't i can't answer that question
quickly because
i mean what my experience we shot that
show for nine months
wow so i had so many experiences
i'm sure shooting that show from
the blistering heat in gettysburg in
july
to the amazing emotional moments i had
with members of the navajo nation and
shipwrecked new mexico
to um a trans man finally having the
wedding of his dreams
with his wife in twin falls and twin
falls
like to it was just it was really
gorgeous
so like this wonderful like mexican mom
crying
getting to see her her son on stage like
being his true authentics it was like
like
he was like having fun and being queer
with his queer friends they didn't feel
the need to hide it from his mom it was
gorgeous
you gotta watch the show yeah i mean and
if you don't you're probably
homophobic that's the marketing plan
the i mean it's it's beautiful do you
have a
one particular memory that like struck
you
the most or one particular situation i
always think about
um meeting uh lady shug and nate ish
and uh ship and shipwreck which is the
farmington episode
and how it was really amazing to see all
the indigenous queer community come
together to help make this performance
because it wasn't just
me and nate it was me and nate and all
of his indigenous friends
who were helping with like he we were
able to use photography
ladies got up and we included activism
about
missing indigenous women and it was
really it was really beautiful wow
is there another season yeah we we we
got picked up for
season two that's incredible um
but we so i assume you have to wait
until the world opens back up a little
bit yeah yeah yeah
now are you working on comedy while in
quarantine i know you're doing youtube
and
uh as much as you can are you working on
like an actual like
show stand-up special well when my last
picture came out
this past february okay my my last
special
so i'm still over kind of riding that
one um i would
love to be a because bob bob dragon
queen live at caroline's
yeah what's your process for putting a
special together
because that's more than just like you
know a 10-minute set or something
yeah it's kind of just like an
amalgamation of things that i've like
i'll talk about some of my friends
and then in the moment oh yeah that's
pretty funny or something i'll bring up
on stage that'll come out of my mouth i
don't know where i was i gotta explore
that
and then i write it out and then i
bounce the ideas off of some of my
comedian friends
particularly my friend mateo lane
i love matteo yeah he helped me flush
out a lot of ideas
and it's helped me save myself has
helped the world from hearing a lot of
really
not fun not funny jokes um
and and we just go back and forth and
then i get up but you know this last
special is honestly legit like i'm so
proud of it
it's it's i'm very proud of it
it's one of the funniest things i've
ever done that's really cool now do you
ever feel
um that you have to prove yourself even
more in the stand-up world
when you come from a drag world or
do you think that's like uh actual like
bender yeah no
no it's it it's both it's both i get a
lot of attention because i'm in drag
but a lot of the comedians themselves
will see me and think like i want to get
up there and do a bunch of like
i'm a man of the dress jokes and and
and i have a few of those
but i have experiences as like a real as
like a
a real life uh human person as well yeah
yeah yeah so are you working on a neck
another special are you taking some time
i mean i'm kind of always working on
this but like i'm always like putting
down jokes but i don't have any current
plans
of doing my next special quite yet
gotcha gotcha
um what are you watching in quarantine
or have you are you a tv
person i become a tv person i watch the
boy i watch the boys
okay yeah it is like on amazon prime i
love love love this show
yeah it's pretty great for forwarding it
is gruesome
it is disturbing it sneaks up on you
all of a sudden uh someone's like actual
neck will explode in front of your face
for like a long time too like they make
you watch
all the way through i mean lots of
trigger warnings here between the
gruesomeness
and like trigger warnings about like
racism
and it's messy it is messy
but it's a great show i love that show
um i started watching utopia yeah i
don't know
i don't know if i'm crazy about utopia
yet it's not terrible i'm just
it's hard to follow yeah i agree i my
boyfriend and i watched the first
two episodes i think and we are like uh
we'll come back to this
i'm at four episodes and i'm like i
shouldn't have this many questions
yeah it's always good to have a few
questions by the end of the episode but
like
i'm like you haven't answered any of my
[ __ ] questions right am i an idiot
are you guys just like making me wait
right now or is it a combination of the
two
right yeah do you watch any reality
television
you know i only really watch reality tv
if it's competition based
really okay and i haven't really watched
any but now i really only watch
football's drag race in terms of reality
tv like this
there's not much i watch out i did watch
james charles's makeup show
by watching the first two episodes not
like skip to the end
and every once in a while i will watch
um what's that makeup show on
netflix oh uh i know what you're talking
about where it's all the the young like
makeup artists are competing
it's got val garland in it and she's
like ding dong
darling this look is
absolutely marvelous i'm gonna say it
i'm gonna say it ding dong
oh it's darling it's so stupid i love it
so
much and she always builds herself up
from like a very
low tone to like screaming she's like
she's like
grace this look you've done today
the colors the textures the
the perfect combination of lace and
and also the contacts that you chose in
these prosthetics
i'm going to say it and everyone's on
the edge of the seat
like people are going into labor there's
like you know
um people are like tearing down madness
it's the it's the golden buzzer from
america's got talent it's like
it's ding dong i want a [ __ ] ding
dong
i know i seen a video of me in my makeup
and be like val can i get a ding dong
right i also feel like it it really
makes you think that you got to start
thinking about what your
what your catchphrase is what's your
tagline what's your ding dong
i don't think i say honestly i don't
think i say first first enough
i barely ever say it like angela is
always saying hallelujah she won't stop
saying halloween eureka's all like
pretty
p-h-a-t pretty hot and tasty and i
never i never say first first they got
well uh
are you tired of it or do you just try
to keep it in the reserves
no i'm not tired of it at all i love
first first oh it's good
it just doesn't come out like first
first isn't a
um it's not a
an exclamation point it's not a
like hallelujah she just said that to
everything hallelujah baby hallelujah
but who's going first first first first
[ __ ] first like
it's a little confusing um
do you have or who would you say
in the drag world gives the worst advice
who gives the worst advice um
and i've got a lot of bad advice
i mean i remember uh i was watching one
episode
of uh all stars no drag i can't remember
what season of drag race it was
10 it was season 10 okay and alyssa was
giving this
this like this advice on like how to lip
sync and i was like i would not
who would do that but
i i always say this but also she does
some really great like she does
something one of the best lipsticks
when she did when she did the annie
oakley thing yeah that was amazing
amazing so yeah i mean i think that she
was anticipating everyone could do what
she does
that's like that's like whenever like
like if naomi campbell or tyra banks is
like
oh you want to pose all you have to do
is look like this and do this and make
this look
like yeah all that plus be a certified
[ __ ] supermom
uh-huh i'm sure that being a supermodel
part didn't hurt yeah exactly
oh a hundred percent um what have you
do you have thoughts about drag race
canada now that they've wrapped their
first season
yeah do you have i was rooting for i was
rooting for priyanka i was very team
so i'm glad that she uh got that crown
oh that's
good yeah i thought it was very sweet
there was a real sense of like
uh it felt very new and very sweet
uh do people come to you for advice
now yeah i don't really give a lot of
advice because
i mean i don't know what the hell i'm
doing myself and that's very refreshing
to hear
like you know i'm like i mean if you
take my advice you're probably going to
end up
literally exactly like me and is that
really what you want
only i really want to do is do the
things that i'm doing so yeah i can tell
you how to be
me but like i don't know i'm not i
wouldn't trust
my advice that well well let's talk
about social media what's your go-to
app or a platform do you love instagram
are you on youtube
um right now right now i've been doing a
lot of take talking but i'm also on
instagram i have the most followers on
instagram
okay um and i'm instagramming i
instagram a lot i
constantly instagram i mean your photos
your photos are beautiful so what's your
process for
um picking the photo for instagram how
do you choose what goes up there
grace i don't think my photos my partner
who takes my photos
picks my photos my partner has is a
really great photographer he takes all
my photos
and he is much better at that stuff than
i am
oh so you have a built-in art director
for you
i do that's fantastic um
have there been any ideas for the
youtube channel that you haven't
shot that have been too stupid or too
dumb or too
just you can't reverse too controversial
um well i have a lot of ideas i i have
this idea
for a um a series called uh
okay i have a theory okay we can change
america if we
flip the carrots hmm
we have to get the cairns on our side
yeah and once we flip the cairns the
rest will just be
easy i agree so there's susie's and
there's karen's
susies are the daughters of karen's
okay yeah now we already have the susies
we have the suzies already we don't have
the cameras
and if i sit down and talk to someone
usually i can explain to them how
america has a problem with systemic
racism they will say this country is
doesn't have a problem racism but
usually
after talking to me and i articulate my
points they're like oh
actually i see what you mean yeah and i
think if i sit down with enough karen's
they'll be like oh
that actually makes sense see this is a
show
i would watch over and over like i think
this should be
produced made done and i want to flip
the cairns
i yeah i mean we want to flip the senate
but i think to do that we gotta flip
some karen's first
and here's the thing let me explain to
you this way okay so
everyone agrees that slavery was bad so
that we don't i don't have to get the
cairns on that side they already believe
that part
they're like but the laws are turned
over now so it's done no no no
let's say you break my arm right it's
not fully atonement
until you help me get a cast you
help me get on antibiotics i don't get
an infection you help me pay for my
rehabilitation
like if if i'm missing work because of
that you give me back money for those
things
and until then you've not atoned for
breaking my arm
so what's been done to the black
community that has egregious has never
been
it's just like no more slavery which by
the way isn't true slavery has never
been abolished it's just been
conditionalized
they're like no more slavery and we're
good now
and then they're also ignoring the years
of jim crow laws
and then the segregation and then all
that they're forgetting and then they're
forgetting the zoning laws that
prevented black people from being able
to move into white neighborhood they're
forgetting
the um the reason why they called but
they was ghettos is because
no we weren't literally physically
forced to move there we were so redlined
not able to move anywhere else that a
lot of like people were forced to live
in the same places
we're like it was just so long ago get
like slave for so long go get over it
i'm like you know it was long ago
jesus dying was long ago no one's
telling you to get over that
you guys are still celebrating easter
get over it it was 2 000 years ago
i hate to tell you but i don't think
he's coming back
yeah like i think he found a better plan
it's like this place sucks
i'm fully leaving but at some point
wouldn't god
look at artists in earth and be like i
gotta cut my losses
yeah they did not go the way i thought
they were gonna go over there
this is a this was a [ __ ] experiment
this is not looking good science has
shown that at some point the earth is
just going to end up
inside the sun randomly anyway right
this is a this is like pandora
it's like if you had pandora and then
spotify came out are you still
listening to the pandora radio
i know i feel like god's up there being
like i gave them scientists and they
won't listen to the scientists i don't
know what to do anymore
that's my losses just you you do it
yourself i'm leaving
oh i love that okay we're gonna take one
last break when we get back i have a
bunch of questions from
instagram for you so we'll be right back
with more not too deep
okay before we get into these instagram
questions i'm going to ask you two
questions ask every single guest those
on the podcast
the first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at
ooh i would really
love let me think about this who would i
want to throw some cold spaghetti at
because it's not
terrible assault it's like that lady who
had hit in the face with a fruitcake
do you remember this do you remember it
was like
the metaphors the symbolism all of it
the poetry in motion
anyway i can't remember it it was a
whole thing but
this was like they threw fruitcake in
this lady or here in the fence
with a fruit pie it was a fruit pie or
something like that okay
and i was like oh my god this is really
beautiful
i think that maybe there's a couple of
uh well maybe some high school bullies
of mine i would love to
i would love to be able to throw cold
spaghetti at them on their wedding day
oh yeah i would i mean but like ninja
style
yeah in and out it was anita bryant
by the way okay okay anita bryant on
october 14 1977 she had a hit in the
face
with a fruit pie oh wow 1977.
okay some history um
okay the other question they ask every
single guest on the podcast is to tell
us your worst pant [ __ ] story
or close call but you can only use three
words
or three small phrases so for example
mine
is college jogging front lawn
mine is um
meeting okay
panera
oh i hope the bread bowl survived after
that one
oh paints a picture okay uh let's get
into
some instagram questions for you real
quick someone asks what accessory should
come into the room
last i mean i don't want to be too
literal but the back of your heel yeah
we're being practical in the way you're
walking it should be the back of your
heel
right yeah that makes sense uh
i love that uh someone to know where
does he buy his hats they're always
fabulous
oh should i go grab one real quick oh
[ __ ] it's like it'll be like a 30-second
moment sure
a full show what's
that i can only imagine i have so many
ideas in my head but i also cannot wait
for the surprise
i mean it's not that exciting i think
i think you have a little bit too much
you have too much high quality
wonderful yeah this is gorg this is
goran brothers
okay they make pretty nice hats oh um
they're a little bit expensive but they
they last well and also look this
hacking like bend
oh and it won't like get [ __ ] i love
it
how many hats do you think you own in
total at this point
well not a lot maybe like ten okay okay
yeah
but i work two over and over again and i
have like i have like three expensive
ones
and like seven really shitty ones have
you thought about
do you know how um you know people make
products they make uh
merch they make all kinds of things is
there a dream item that you would love
to
put your name on yeah well i kind of
wanted to make a line of like
genderless clothes like i wear like some
genderless like
sex like these like yeah bags like that
i wear
perfect but they're like multi-seasonal
yeah i mean to be fair they're probably
just women's clothes that i'm calling
genderless
but because i wear them they look
genderless and i really love the idea of
like making a
line of like genderless sacks for people
who
who want to be comfortable and aren't
necessarily trying to show off like a
whole lot of their body
yeah i love that i also just love the
name genderless sax
i think genderless sex fifth avenue
yeah exactly uh someone asked
who is the all-time most underrated
queen from drag race
um i'm gonna go with
jayden dior fierce oh yeah she does not
get the credit she deserves she's a
really
really great directly oh that's great to
know
uh okay someone wants to know if you
were to write a book what would it be
about
they said they would read it regardless
of what it's about i've had a couple of
books that usually revolve
around like african-american history
usually
like i had an idea for a while a while
back for a book about
a a professor of african american
studies
who finds a way to time travel
but his time travel is through
possession so it's not like so he can
he'll go back but he is someone else
back in time
oh okay so he slips into the the person
yeah so he was going back in time and
embodying this slave
um but then when you get stuck whoa
i think that's a great idea for a book
uh
so you have lots of projects to do it
sounds like you're just creating a lot
of work for yourself
someone asked what do you expect the
drag world will turn into
it's kind of a difficult question i'm
sure i'm i'm certainly not the
nostradamus of drag
um and i have no clue what the [ __ ]
people i mean i i have not
accurately predicted a single drag trend
since i started dragged so don't listen
to me whatever i say
is the opposite i love it uh someone
wants to know did you play with other
personas before you got into drag
uh before you landed on bob yeah
so bob is not really a persona bob is
just
my work name like i don't i don't do
different i'm not like
being different or acting different or
talking funny right i don't do any of
that stuff when i'm in drag
so but i did have a concept for a
character named erica about don't
and um eric about don't was just like
drag queen who were like head wraps
was barefoot and like
did erica baduisms you know that's great
um i just told you what not to do
constantly
uh someone wants to know if you could do
drag makeup or hair on any celeb
who would it be you know i don't love
putting people in drag
really yeah yeah i'm not like i'm not
i'm not a makeup artist
and i mean i do my own makeup but like
because i have to not because i'm like i
can't wait to put the brush on the face
today
i don't really have a desire to put
anyone in drag like
i if i was going to spend some time with
a celebrity i wouldn't spend time
putting them in drag
how about just a celebrity that you'd
want to sit down and have a conversation
with
well i try to see if there's a celebrity
i can actually collaborate with
so like i wouldn't want to just hang out
with one
but if there's someone that i really
want to work with i'd be like i try to
get a bug in their
ear like i have an idea that one day i
want to do a movie where me and leslie
jones
are siblings i would love that
like it's happening yeah i feel like
you're manifesting a lot of stuff
right now that's gonna be really good
uh someone wants to know what's the most
uncomfortable thing about tucking
i mean i guess just shoving your junk
like the whole the whole thing the whole
thing
the whole family after a while it's not
uncomfortable you kind of get used to it
sorry i'm just gonna
i'm sitting on the floor so i'm trying
to like oh my god you're doing your best
and we appreciate it there we go
but you know when you tuck your
testicles go inside your body so
the first the first time that's a little
bit uncomfortable oh i'm i
can only imagine uh someone wants to
know how many characters did you prepare
for snatch game
um three just the three yeah
goldberg they're great i mean they were
so
did you to be able to switch characters
halfway through
were you really confident in that choice
or was that something you kind of like
did i was looking forward to it i was
excited and looking forward for sure
this is going to be great uh okay last
question for you someone asked can we
get a few bullet points on how to be a
good drag
fan
good question i mean i think that this
is just my opinion by the way so someone
else would not agree with this
sure i first of all don't don't
ever touch anything
from my sternum up ah
like don't grab my fake boobs i get it
they're not my boobs but like
don't grab them people do that a lot
like people grab your tits
all the time and dress wow i mean and
just because they're not yours doesn't
mean that there's someone else's exactly
um don't don't touch my face even for a
kiss
do not kiss me on the cheek don't put
your hand don't reach up and grab my
face don't touch my hair
and i also make sure i don't touch the
like i don't touch people
yeah i mean especially now like you
can't but even before
yeah like if anyone ever saw a picture
of me with a fan if you look at the
picture from behind
my hand is usually hovering over the
hover hand yeah
like i don't i don't touch people no
that's good
unless we're friends and we're and we're
we're cool around that level
yeah um but yeah i don't like i don't
like the touching it and it also there's
also this weird thing that people do
and this isn't just drag thing but like
when
someone compliments you and then you say
thank you and they go no
no i'm serious it's like it's like this
it's like this i'm gonna do it you
compliment me
okay now no wait how does it work i'll
be the fan obviously
you're ready okay yeah grace your
podcast is really
brilliant oh thank you so much no no i'm
serious
i'm being serious okay uh
i didn't think you were joking but thank
you no i know i'm telling you listen i
look into a lot of podcasts
and yours is great and i'm not kidding
so like it's really good
oh wow yeah that is an uncomfortable
thing to get out of
and that's what it's like it's like just
let me just just say you're welcome
i don't know yeah no i'm serious i said
oh you're so kind no i'm not nice
i'm actually a [ __ ]
usually i don't mean this when i say it
but i mean it for you
i'm like jesus christ i am uncomfy
um bob we've reached the end of the
podcast but before you go
uh we like to give the guests a little
gift for making time for us and we've
sent you i believe melissa has emailed
you a personalized fortune cookie from
us to you
it says a beautiful smart and loving
person will come into your life
none of them are in this room
it's the fortune so keep your eyes
peeled
there it is a beautiful smart and wait
what was that
beautiful smart and loving oh my
goodness
get ready los angeles they have all
kinds of those people here
uh bob where can people find everything
that you're up to if they don't already
know and what do you have coming up
you go to bobdragqueen.com and all my
stuff is
uh listed there every single thing
season two we're here is gonna be coming
out
uh some more ivory podcast season four
just dropped
um and of course every week i'm really
seeing videos on youtube
amazing and we can all look for flip the
cairns in the near to distant future
we need it bob thank you so much for
being here ever
go check out everything that he's up to
it's always hilarious also
um i have to say your mom is so adorable
on your youtube channel
so so sweet uh thank you again guys
we'll see you on another episode of not
too
deep goodbye too deep too deep
too deep deep not too deep with christ
not too deep as a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis post
production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music